Speaker 1: Former Democratic Congresswoman Tulsi
Gabbard, who now regularly speaks at anti-vaccine
events, seemed to shock even Fox News host
Jesse WATTERS when she compared affirmative
action ideas and the idea of having that. And
even she compared Biden to Hitler. I don't even
know how else to say it. This you have to
see the general subject matter. During the
former congresswoman's interview with Jesse
Waters, was Biden, quote, choosing diversity
over competence, which, by the way, there's
no evidence at all that Joe Biden has done.
And she said these are the principles that the
Nazis and Hitler embodied. She has really taken
well to this new role as an anti woke free speech
or whatever they call her at this point. Right.
Speaker 3: Their philosophy, identity,
politics. And this is one of the main
reasons why left right Democratic.
Speaker 1: By the way, I'm sorry to
already interrupt. I wonder if remember, Tulsi
is against identity politics. Will she come out
against the identity politics campaign of Nikki
Haley, who's like, I don't really know of any
reason that you would vote for me over Trump on
policy, but like I'm younger and a woman and of
Indian heritage is she is is because Tulsi, of
course, would never play partizan games. Okay.
Sorry. Let's take it from the top here.
Speaker 3: Their philosophy, identity,
politics. And this is one of the main reasons
why I left the Democratic Party, because they
are seeing how their agenda of identity politics
is directly undermining the traditional democratic
values that were expressed so beautifully
and clearly by Dr. Martin Luther King that
we should judge each other not based on the color
of our skin, but based on our character. And yet,
as you have displayed here over and over of
example after example, they're proud to be
judging people, hiring people, selecting people
based on race, which is really let's be clear,
how serious of a problem this is. Yeah, it's
based on genetics, race, based on your blood,
your genes. And where do we see that connection?
Well, these are the very same geneticists core
principles embodied by Nazism and Adolf Hitler.
And this should be something that is sickening and
alarming to every single Democrat and every.
Speaker 1: It's sickening and alarming
to me that Tulsi would say this.
Speaker 3: Single American we have
seen where this philosophy can lead.
Speaker 1: Right. Noticing, hey,
we dramatically underrepresented, for example,
black women in the judiciary. Maybe we could like
make them slightly less under representative.
Next thing you know, they'll be coming to kill
the Jews. It's exactly the thing. This
is insane. Now, you all know me on this
issue. I don't believe that we can even remotely
have a Jewish judiciary that exactly matches the
American population along every demographic line.
I have not heard anyone on the left say, listen,
the population is like 50.5% women. So 50.5% of
all judges should be women and white people make
up what is it now, like 69% of the population. So
we need 69% of the population of the judiciary to
be white. And then 12% of the population is 55
to 64. I'm making that number up now. So 12% of
the judiciary must be 55 to 60. Nobody that
I have seen, myself included, is calling for
that type of equality of. Outcome when it comes
to the judiciary. What Joe Biden has identified
is that the judiciary is already dramatically
unrepresentative of the population at large.
So Joe Biden, during his tenure so far, has
nominated disproportionately more black women
to the judiciary. That's true. And we still
have a dramatic under-representation of black
women in the judiciary. Joe Biden has only made it
slightly more reflective of the population. Now,
what the right loves to say is because of the
prioritization of identity over competency,
by virtue of appointing a lot of black,
a lot comparatively more black women,
we are reducing the competency because they're
being chosen not for their judicial acumen,
but instead because of their racial identity.
This is one of the dumbest things that they
claim when they want to act against the act
against affirmative. So-called affirmative
action under the guise of identity politics.
This is a country of 331 million people.
My guess is if you said we are going to have
a judiciary that is 70% black women, there are
enough competent black women judges that you could
do it and they would all be competent. Similarly,
if you said we're going to have 80% of the
judiciary be Asian people. Oh, but isn't that
going to choose racial identity over competition?
We have 331 million people in this country,
and we have enough competent Asian jurists that
you could do that. So the issue is not that we are
choosing incompetent people based only on their
race. It's we have so many competent people of
all races in this country that if you say, well,
I'm going to over select a group that has been
historically under selected, you're choosing
from all competent people. That's the reality.
And there doesn't sound anything like Nazi ism in
it to me. If you disagree with me, let me know.